thank you
[Music]
all right everybody our next guest once
saying Play That Funky Music on stage
with Prince and he's also one of the
most prolific filmmakers and honestly
just figures people humans comedians
director writer artists of our time
please welcome the one and only Tyler
Perry
[Applause]
how's everybody
thank you thank you thank you please
well okay before the break we actually
threw out a tease about
um three possible fears yeah
um germs tunnels and spinach which of
the two are you actually afraid of
there are two that I'm afraid of okay
which ones are they germs and tunnels
yeah yeah yeah why so covered must have
been great for you well listen no what
happened was I was on tour yeah I was
performing about three 400 performances
a year live and I got the flu in in
Tennessee very early on worst thing that
ever happened I had to perform 18 shows
wrapped in a blanket because I wouldn't
cancel so I just became a uh I washed my
hands it didn't want to shake and do all
this stuff so I was I was ahead of covet
on this
by the way it's true whenever I'm like
pumping a hand sanitizer somewhere and
it's empty I'm like no we should keep
caring yes eat this up exactly right I
feel like we lived for a hundred years
with everyone like hi nice to meet you
yes we can end that yeah and who
invented this handshake thing I mean
it's like it's so weird I like this hi
that works just stay over there also I
get a lot of clams yeah clams uh like
wet clammys yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's not that's never good
it happens a lot and you're just like
why no you're that way I'm going no no
can you drive that let's uh let's let's
dry your hands so we can actually we can
shake well you have boundaries I'll do
it like your hand baby
that works by the way like one of the
closest I got to you which I was so
excited was Gail King yeah yeah um she
was on the show
um we were talking about you and you
know what I think we have a clip it'll
explain it better you notice I wore my
flower in honor of you yes and then
Tyler Perry texted something about how
he hated it
he hated the flower he thought it looked
like a big orange wound and I said I did
it you know for you
um so no no no no
no no no no no
that's fine the the the flowers she had
on looked like a womb like she had been
shot in the shoulder that's fine that's
a little Overkill but that's fine it did
look like a wound yeah
um I'm actually seeing Gail this evening
with that um well I was wondering if
there's any chance I could get you to
take a picture with me
would you ever
like
oh that's perfect oh my God thank you
okay perfect who's got the camera Gail
King
I want to leave your face
just a little bit
you know what's so great is you just
handled that like such a director oh
yeah I want your face in the shop put
your face in the flowers not too much I
want to see it but like right here it's
interesting because that actually segues
into being a director is like an all-in
thing how are you so prolific how do you
write produce and direct as many
projects as often as you do I I I wish
that I could tell you that I I I this is
what I do when I do this and I do that
but I I I was I bought up in the
business the first time I ever did a
play I I wrote it directed it I I was
selling candy I was running backstage
during intermission I was on stage so I
trained myself to do a lot of things I
don't know how not to do it you know and
it wasn't out of out of just I wanted to
be involved in everything it was just I
was broke couldn't afford to pay anybody
so I had to learn every job which has
served me very very well but I don't
know how not to do it so when someone
says that to me that that's not 400
strings I have people that work for me
who worked on in Hollywood and worked on
other shows and they're like this is
impossible this is not how it's done how
are you going away for two weeks and
coming back with 22 Episodes how are we
shooting 22 Episodes in two weeks how
are we doing that but for me it just
something about my brain it just seems
so what do you say to them in that
circumstance I wish I
I wish I could say that I understood it
but I didn't come up in this Hollywood
System so I don't know that it's how
rare that is how do you inspire them
you're like okay we're gonna do 22
Episodes by doing this or we're going to
do all of this work that seems
impossible and I'm going to say this is
the sort of this is the direction I'm
going to give you for that this is the
motivation this is the systems what how
do you cajole Inspire and like make it
happen make the impossible I'm on set
with them every day and everything so
I'm there 12 14 hours a day side by side
arm and arm with them moving it forward
and having uh this what else has helped
is having people who have never done it
before so they didn't come up in a
system that said this is how it has to
be done they came up in a system that
says no this is how we do it and it
doesn't seem foreign or strange to them
I mean if it was like it feels like
we're just doing a normal job I have a
question for you okay if you can only
write produce or act for the rest of
your life what would you choose
writing
writing yeah because
because I never I never had a day of
therapy but what I did was I would write
and from the time Oprah said on her show
when I was a kid she said it was
cathartic to write things down I started
writing and I was using different
characters names because of the subject
matter I was talking about I didn't want
somebody to find it and realize I had
been through those kinds of things but
writing for me was the therapy in the
sense of if if a character got up and
moved from one sofa to the other I'm
like well why do they do that and I had
to trace chase down their motivation so
I started applying it to my own life
well why do you feel that way when
somebody said this and I chased down the
motivation to something that had
happened to me in the past so in
understanding that it was like a puppet
master with a string that's making you
behave a certain way when something
happens by chasing down the motivation I
was unable to tie on tie string by
string in my own life so the writing has
been phenomenally important to me did
you ever think oh Oprah taught me to be
a writer to help me get in touch with
things to become the person I am and
then I'm going to become really good
friends with her and like help her run
her network is that a beautiful full
circle moment for you to admire someone
and then have that reciprocity with them
really it really is even the
understanding of feeling as a kid
running home from television she came at
three o'clock in New Orleans and I come
home to watch a show all the time
because I wanted to see what she was
talking about to feel like in that
moment a broke kid in New Orleans with
nothing like I know you like I feel so
connected to you I know millions of
people did but I felt like I really know
you and then to get a phone call from
her I have to die with a Mad Black Woman
comes out I'm walking down this is what
Oprah do I'm walking down the street in
Vegas my phone rings and I'm about to
cross the street and I said hello I'm
like who's this hello hey it's Oprah and
I I'm about to get killed because I'm
stepping out in traffic because she's
just calling me blind and cold like that
and 18 years later we've become great
friends so here we are
okay you're so brilliant it is very hard
to cut to commercial but we're gonna go
and then we'll be right back with This
brilliant man
[Music]